[Music]
william here we are how's it going
fantastic now can we just do a little uh
top to toe thing because
you're wearing probably the best
trainers i've seen you where certainly
in the last
three to four years these were a present
so i didn't choose them myself which is
probably why they're so
attractive what was it your stylish wife
it was my wife and son brilliant of
great colors you like them very cool i'd
like you boring them but you get bigger
feet than me slightly bigger feet but
your cool meter
has gone up i'd say at least 17
i like the trousers they look like
moleskin are they they feel really good
upon your buttocks yeah you're still
working on your buttocks yeah they're
working hard actually done yeah squats
squats lunges step ups step downs
step to the sides all sorts of stepping
stepper mantic stuff if you were yeah if
you want to get your buttocks bigger you
have to move your legs are here also a
high fat diet so could i recommend maybe
putting some you know
butter or lard on your pizza i don't
mind stirring some uh duck fat into your
pasta
is that good for your butt well for some
people yeah when they retain fat they
retain it in certain areas ladies
classically retain their fat more around
the thigh and buttock area men
around the santa belly area which is as
an indicator of a bad hailstone i'm a
little uh predisposed to that too my
wonderful father has has been fashioning
of santa belly and he looks pretty good
with it your dad always looks fantastic
before we bring in our guests i had one
question that i wanted to ask you
because this might not be something that
we answer today this might be an ongoing
thing for people at home to think about
and for you and i to think about but i
saw this thing online i thought this is
a great question to ask billy
the fellowship uh actually the two
towers trilogy no two towers trilogy
there's only one two towers i'm drunk on
red bull
the
lord of the rings trilogy yeah has a
pg-13 rating in the united states yeah
that means
that in each
of the movies yep you can have one swear
word where would you put that swear word
are you really yeah for instance
in the fellowship of the ring i could
say
[__] buckle berry ferry follow me
and you could get it past the census but
wouldn't that be brilliant
so we're i want to ask people at home
where is the best place in each movie
because i could go [__] full of
attack
or before like when i know they're
scouting that i could go oh i'm really
[__] sorry again
or the best one that i've thought about
to now
in um
to the king and send in your suggestions
if you have any
but [__] paragon my friends you
[__] bout to know
[Laughter]
so send in your suggestions yeah where
would you put the swear words it's one
the only one now what if you said
like say for instance sean bean
and in the minds of moria when you say
one
could he say i've got a [__]
cave troll
is that one
[__] is uh is one swear word
right right okay but then that's it for
the rest of the movie that's that any
anything anybody else wanted to swear no
no so when when frodo and gandalf having
a little moment in the minds of moria
and frodo says there's someone following
us gandalf could not then say no it's
[__] gollum i've already had it he's
been following us for [__] days and
then return of the king all the way
through four and a half hours no swear
words right up till sam comes home
i'm [__] home
[Laughter]
it's the gift that keeps on giving
aragorn running into the final battle
for [__] frodo
all right well should we bring our guest
in we're very excited let's have a song
before we do that guys
love exciting in you
come aboard
we're expecting you
honestly i never really watched the love
boat but pitch it to me is people
isolated on boats kissing and hugging
each other is that what's good i've
never seen the loved ones have you seen
um nowadays it'd be called like the sex
cruise or something
have you seen fantasy island no is that
the plane the plane yeah no never saw
they're both basically the same show
certain different things isolated
they're on a boat
the love boat yeah
and you know you get to know the captain
cappy the the guy who helps people out
chef
the lady who welcomes
hostess
another guy who helps out but not as
much he likes to hide in the toilet is
it why does he have irritable bowel
syndrome he's just having a break but
all these people
invite people on every week different
people and they're all looking for love
dog
and they might find it in the most
unusual places oh well you sometimes do
orifices and stuff is that what you mean
so basically that was the love ball but
the reason i'm singing it the love i
remember that bit very 70s right fantasy
island the same sort of thing you get to
know the guy who owns the island
the owner
they are a little guy who helps him out
the plane
and now he's scared of planes is that
what it is no but the plane comes every
week with new people we have definitely
they have ideas for different adventures
on fantasy island and whatever your
fantasy is you want to be the ceo of a
huge company or you want to be the hero
in your own story well we all are you'd
like to be the lady who invented um
oh yes
yeah or penicillin both both helpful
everybody who invented anything of any
use was scottish the telephone what was
the name of the guy invented the
telephone alexander bell he's scottish
really scottish tarmac
tarmac
as they call it head asphalt yeah that
he was scottish
uh waterproof waterproof
clothing
scottish
the fridge freezer
scottish you wouldn't have thought you'd
need that in scotland it did it by
accident he's trying to heat himself up
and if you've noticed the back of a
fridge is hot
true he accidentally
made a fridge by trying to heat himself
up wow he's an accidental genius
yeah he put a heater behind the box and
the inside of the box got really cold so
he kept his eggs in there wow well
here's another thing yeah why
are we keeping our eggs in the fridge
chickens don't only in america chickens
don't keep their eggs in the fridge and
britain you don't need to no well you
don't know you don't need to in america
sure no you do why because the they're
looked
they're looked after in different ways
the chickens no the eggs whatever they
do eggs over here yeah before they go to
like ralphs or vaughn's or wherever
those are supermarkets in the united
states for people um before they go
there they do something to them all
right they
they wave something over them a light or
something right ultraviolet or something
and after you do that to an egg
you have to keep it in the fridge in
britain it sounds like you're making it
up honestly that sounds like you're
making that i've looked that up but i
just scanned the article
so it's absolutely true but i don't know
what as america does that britain
doesn't have you seen that moment where
they check they scan the eggs to see if
there's a baby chicken inside or if
there's not a baby chicken inside of
yourself
it's a light
and they sweep a light over it and if
there's a baby chick inside it glows
orange and if it's just an egg inside it
doesn't that was it
because it's unfertilized doesn't it
yeah but sometimes the [__] eh can uh
get in there it gets and amongst the
chickens the roots will get sent amongst
the chickens you know the difference
between a rooster and a cockroach mm-hmm
come on
it's nothing to do with tapes does it
yeah no
spelling is it's just a different one
but they're exactly the same thing
um all right well that's everything that
scotland's invented do you know the
first ever railway on the planet was in
manchester england where did it go from
into just went town sent here to a mill
i think because it's cotton industry so
i think
maybe some sort of textile mill
but yeah first ever railway on the
planet was in manchester which
revolutionized the planet
incredible the first time someone tried
to make a railroad they thought that the
the
the wheels
and the railway track would have to be
like cogs
oh right like
not serrated what do you call that with
a zip with a cog like cogs
cocked cogged
but you don't need that because the way
the train holds on
so there you are so maybe that was a guy
in manchester did that should we bring
in our guests
and it's a guest about love which is why
i sang the love
love
monday tuesday
wednesday
he's not from the love book but he's
from somewhere else where people have
found love oh well i can see the tie in
there so we're bringing in our friend we
were actually on our friend nick's
podcast i don't know a few
a few months back now nick vial yep and
um
it was a great we had a great time
talking about us
launching our podcast and asking him
about it and we've actually launched it
on the vial files yeah which is uh which
is next
um well let's bring nick in and then we
can ask nick a whole bunch of things
nick if you're listening
hi nick do you want to come in
come on it's good we've kept a chair for
you it's good nick we'll move around so
you feel more comfortable
it's a little salty a little multi
if there's anyone from marmite who wants
billy and i to um
do the commercials and promote the uh
product or even just send us some stuff
there's some amazing marmite t-shirts
out there
please send them to us because we'll
wear them on the podcast and you'll get
free advertising yeah but if you want us
to write the next jingle we'll do that
i'll do it i love marmite now yeah i've
loved marmite for like a good 30 years
but billy's new to marmite and it's
turned into one of your favorite new
discoveries doesn't it i'll tell you
something who's got no idea what marmite
is nick nick no idea nick should we tell
you should we pitch you marmite
see if i feel like you just did well i
did but i don't know if we were i don't
know if we were rolling at that point
maybe we were um
but it's it's um eaten
primarily by students in
all over britain because it is a
relatively cheap spread savory spread
they tend to put on toast or beans on
toast or stir it into your
sauces or your gravies to make it a
little bit more tasty it's a classic
probably the classic student food isn't
it
dark dark thick
black is night
and it's very very strong it's a very
strong flavor people either love it or
hate it we're going to get you a tub
yeah as a gift i don't think tom would
be would you call that i would say john
it's a jar yeah
we think tub is more plasticky
i guess also it sounds like there might
be like a it would require a whole truck
to deliver it no no no no you can get
them like that big or you can get
whoppers i get i get whoppers but my
all-time favorite sandwich
stick with me here nick
brown bread
english butter
mature english cheddar
slices of green apple
rocket i think you guys call it arugula
arugula arugula
marmite
crisps
the other bread
flavor of crystal that's a vlog it's a
very intimidating sound it's a bit
intimidating i would say top of the list
for the flavour of chris salton vinegar
number two jalapeno number three cheese
and onion i would have said salt and
vinegar yeah
it's an intense intense sandwich a
sensibility of the day type of sandwich
where if you have two or three bites i
need to put it down and say right give
me a minute let me let me just process
that because it's it's a complicated set
of flavors but [__] me it's good
we'll bring you we'll bring you marmite
we really will i i hope so i'll i'll
have to i'll take your word for it
because actually i've i've thought about
you dominic a lot nick since our last
podcast
sorry billy but
when we talked when you were on my show
you you talked about your love for
animals in your backyard and how animals
are speaking languages we can't possibly
and i don't know if i had
my dog jeff when i had you your dog's
called jeff his name's jack
i like you a lot more nick uh thanks
yeah and and since i and i got jeff in
june july jeff in june
and uh
i got uh
a small backyard but very private kind
of a sanctuary type of area and
i
i pay attention to jeff as he
kind of reacts to certain things yeah my
first reaction is like what
what the [__] are you barking at
and i think of you because i realized
that
there are things going on that i can't
see absolutely i mean billy he's barking
at like little rodents or whatever
absolutely and i always smell from
two he's like you know
three quarters of a mile away a squirrel
climbed a tree and that wind took 30
seconds to get to your dog or billy's
dogs and they'll go squirrel yeah and
then they go and we don't know we don't
know about it now and i've done this
scientifically because i've got a dog
bobby bobby johnson and i have
scientifically
farted
very close to you scientifically found
yeah well you do it with a pen and paper
yeah i am working out with the pencils
the calculator
and then i'll gradually go further and
further away and i can get to the end of
main street
and bobby will still notice that far
[Music]
brilliant
i think of you yeah yeah man i mean look
we're all animals we're all in the
animal kingdom we have through our
evolution as humans
kind of pulled ourselves further and
further away from the connection to all
these other animals but certainly dogs
and cats and squirrels and snakes and
spiders they are much more connected to
each other for good reason because some
of these animals can kill the other
animals and some of them have food and
some of them are prey so
the frequency that your dogs have in
their ears to listen to other dogs or to
listen for squirrels or to listen for
snakes or all that kind of stuff is way
more heightened than a humans would be
yeah that's right jeff likes horses
uh-huh anytime they're on tv he's a big
fan of this show called yellowstone are
you familiar with it oh yeah my friend
hassie harrison is on that okay is that
kevin costner as well yeah dances with
wolves yeah fantastic but it's amazing
how he likes he loves horses who kev
jeff oh jeff yeah yeah kev is like also
but there's it's not every single dog
that recognizes a tv is it like so dude
he's my first dog so i'm i'm no it's
good dad your dog watched the television
no it doesn't it doesn't lose the tv
recognize the telly it's nothing no see
doesn't matter what's going on in the tv
it it it's as if it doesn't exist you
could have dogs on barking you know
yeah you see that oh jeff jeff responds
to the tv as soon as it's on that's
amazing yeah so i wonder what that is
about but that's great i have a friend
called jamie wozney who does a whole
bunch of things in la but one of the
things that she does in la is
she does an animal communication course
so if you're wanting to try and have
more of a profound relationship with
jeff or any animal she'll take you
through this course of trying to have
you understand how to connect a little
closer with those animals it's funny
have you taken the course yeah
yeah it was really fun i've got a friend
doing it right now actually interesting
uh hello chelsea well should we talk
about um
another and other places in new york
that yeah that wasn't the borough in new
york and london that was my friend
chelsea who lives in costa rica who's
taking an animal communication course
unlike other restrictive diets or
workout programs noon weight uses
psychology to empower you with the
practical knowledge and skills you need
to build smarter more sustainable
long-term habits and behaviors noom
isn't like other trendy diets it
actually helps you get to a healthier
you which is why i love using it num
allows it to be about the process with
ups and downs i hate a diet when i feel
like i can't eat anything but num
actually educates me on how to be
healthy to help me reach my goals you're
the boss you decide how nume weight fits
into your life not the other way around
5 10 or 15 minutes a day how much time
do you want to spend on the app is
entirely up to you dom more than 60 of
users lose 5 or more body weight by 16
weeks wow and more than 60 of users
engaged with the program keep the weight
off for over a year or more that's
amazing noom is driven by a singular
mission to help as many people as
possible live healthier lives through
behavioral changes they use the latest
in proven behavioral science to empower
people to take control of their health
for good and through a combination of
psychology technology and human coaching
their platform has helped millions of
users meet their personal health and
wellness sign up for your trial and get
psychology based support and motivation
to reach your goal at n o o m dot com
slash onion that's n o o m dot com slash
onion to sign up for your free trial
billy you know i love cereal i like to
eat cereal not just for breakfast
sometimes i like it as a little snack
after my workout sometimes i like it
when i'm watching a film and we're all
trying to eat better especially now in
the new year but healthy breakfast
doesn't have to be boring magic spoon
has amazing flavors you'll love but
without all the bad stuff and it's
amazing as i said as a midnight snack
right before bed here's some facts tom 0
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving only 140 calories a serving
build your own box available flavors to
build your very own custom bundle are
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberries cinnamon cookies and cream
and maple waffle they're all very
delicious super yummy so go to
magicspoon.com to grab a custom bundle
of cereal and start your new year off
just right and be sure to use our promo
code onion at the checkout to get five
dollars off your order and magic spoon
is so confident in their product it's
back with a 100 happiness guarantee so
if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember
get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode
we have questions about this
okay
we've got lots of questions about the
back because i'm a bachelor are you a
bachelor currently
no okay are you married no i mean so it
depends on how you just define bachelor
but i am in a committed relationship so
yeah you're not a bachelor because
bachelor is a single man
now maybe your dog is attracted to the
tv because you're a tv personality
i don't think he would respond well he
might respond to me on the tv what do
you think he would notice it was you
it's a good question yeah let's try it
well it's hard because he's so attentive
to the tv in general i wouldn't really
know
yeah it would be interesting if i was
gone and and natalie my girlfriend
put on a show that i was on you must
keep the tv on when you're out to her no
have some company for him no he's cuddle
trained so we'll put him away in his
kennel he likes it okay he goes it
depends if we're gone for like extended
periods of time we'll put him in his
kennel so it's more to keep him safe
i've been flirting with getting a dog
but i'm nowhere closer to uh just
flirting
uh i never had a dog in my life
billy's had grown up with dogs and had a
bunch of dogs and i love i think my
favorite dog ever is bob he's a great
job yeah so
not to sound dramatic but it's kind of
it's changed my life i got a tattoo of
him right here oh yeah i see him
look at that uh
well he taught me the value
of being unconditionally liked and how
that's better than being unconditionally
loved well i'll talk about that
extrapolate well your mom
unconditionally loves you
you know nobody kidding but she still
thinks you're an [__] sometimes yeah
yeah you know yeah so it's like
it's like yeah you know when people say
they unconditionally love you it's
almost like they almost have to right
there's a sense of like
um responsibility you know like your
sister your sibling and they've learned
to appreciate you
but a dog unconditionally likes you like
jeff's the
only living thing in this world that
i've encountered
that likes everything about me always
likes you and that's a great feeling
because i know that
i i don't have like i have qualities
that people don't like
you know like even your girlfriend
you're being annoying or what you know
what i'm saying we get on people's
nerves
and well maybe jeff makes me feel like i
can't i can i never get under
maybe the way that jeff shows that he's
not really into you right now
doesn't
resonate in a way that feels like you're
unliked maybe when bobby or jeff is a
little bit like now i'm kind of done
with this human
they jump off your lap and go sit in the
kennel and have a little half hour to
themselves and you might be possible
that's great they just have fun i don't
know why you want to ruin this phone i'm
just i'm just putting out there uh that
that could be also happening it's
possible yeah uh but
it i'll yeah
he makes me feel that regardless of
whether it's true or not and it's a nice
feeling that's a great thing i do hear a
lot of the times with people who have
dogs that say ah the great thing about
dogs is
they're so selfless and they they love
you and they're always happy to see you
and they're always happy to do whatever
you want to do which seems to be the
case
it's true with the owner or possibly the
owner's significant other or family and
stuff but they don't do that with
everyone do that
the dogs the dogs they'll do dogs are
actually very single-minded about about
what they want to do like if you say
sit
they probably will do it for their owner
but if it's someone else saying sit
they're like no i'm not gonna sit for
you he's some he often does it for me
also like for for me it's like jeff and
i are very close natalie natalie and i
lived together my girlfriend
and she she's just an incredibly likable
person
so i just i just i've accepted and i
quite like what i like about her
is is
again she's very likable so i i just
feel like if it was like a one-off if
people like
weren't worried about feelings
everyone just likes her more than they
like me except for jeff that's like you
and me which is really nice like it's
just like he
he's we have a bond natalie he likes
natalie he loves natalie but jeff and i
are very close and and jeff's the only i
think jeff's the only person who would
pick me over natalie ah yeah i think
everyone would pick billy over me except
for nick yeah maybe you like me more
than uh really to close races well let's
wait until we get i thought about you
more because of what you taught me
thanks nick dog my dog definitely likes
my wife more than me yeah i've seen that
yeah if we're all sat watching a movie
bobby's favorite position is to sit just
to the left of ali
yeah loves it okay which is one of my
favorite places to sit i bet he'll come
and say hello to guests quite a lot
about me you'll come check me out yes a
little bit of hanging out for like 10 15
minutes see if you've got anything going
on are you going to give me a stroke
type thing but when he really wants to
settle down he goes and hangs out next
to ali i love dogs always love them the
only sad thing about a dog and i don't
want to bring this up just now because
you've got a
as long as humans
and that is incredibly
painful
i've already as soon as i got him i i
started worrying about that because with
i i'm allergic to most dogs
and jeff's not uh hyperallergenic and so
you know i've always liked dogs but as
someone who's who has allergies to it's
like most short-haired dogs it's the
dandruff
and
so you know i've learned to keep my
distance and not cuddle
who doesn't sleep in your bed jeff does
no he does well i wasn't sure because so
i spent most of my life just having
boundaries with dogs because i didn't
you know i wasn't sure how i would react
and um
and then i i played with jeff's dad
before jeff was born it was kind of like
can i
well i have a reaction and i did it and
so
yeah i had some boundaries
i was like oh jeff will see this kind of
i'll we'll have some boundaries but now
jeff sleeps on my head sometimes lovely
and what type of doggy is jeff he's an
australian cobra dog it's like a golden
doodle oh lovely lovely but a more
specific uh
he's a they're bred to be uh therapy
dogs apparently oh he's called han yeah
companions yeah right
i remember viggo wrote the i think some
of my favorite work that vigo ever does
is
what are you laughing at
80 your face twenty what does that do in
my face it's just funny no thanks and
twenty percent i hope you're going to
tell this story that i think you're
gonna no i don't think i am because this
is actually a sad story
i love you can tell it though i love
viggo as an actor he's a brilliant
photographer vigo great painter but i
think my favorite medium that viggo
works in alongside acting is poetry he's
a really brilliant poet viggo mortensen
and he wrote a poem
about his dog having died
and he goes to pick up
the ashes of his dog and he talks about
i can't remember specifically but he's
like you know we used to run in the
field and do this i used to throw a
stick for you and you used to chase
after a bone and all this kind of stuff
and now
you're a pile of dust in my hand and it
was brilliantly realized that poem so
yeah i guess we should all just kill
ourselves
he also tells a story about that dog
where
um he he was somewhere else when it died
this dog
[Music]
he was somewhere else when it died and
he had to go and pick up its body from
the vet
to take it back to where they
you know where they were from and it was
like a five hour drive
taking it back to get it cremated to
become ashy
so he picked up the dog and it's in like
a bag obviously and and he put it on the
passenger seat and he had this five-hour
drive back home to where they were from
and
he said he was speaking to it this is in
one of his books the story i read it
and he spoke to this dog all the way
home reminiscing about all the lovely
times they had and all that getting
ready for him to be cremated and when he
got him home and took him out the bag
it wasn't his dog
giving him the wrong talk oh that's
terrible
and that dog had to listen to all those
stories that he wasn't involved in
because vega can bang on can i tell you
what it can really bang on that's a sad
and funny story yeah it's poetic in
itself but is that enough about dogs
just very hold on this is only tiny but
do you remember elijah had a dog
in the in the [__] do you know what i'm
gonna say yeah in the twilight of his
years the dog got kind of randy oh no oh
yeah what was that what were you gonna
say i was gonna say his dog likes to
stare at the wall
it will sit three inches away from the
wall and just look at the wall does have
a new dog for hours i don't know if it's
the same i don't know if this is randy
thought like a magna doodle no that the
randy dog's dead tell me about the randy
dog the randy dog wasn't randy like
horny for like a lot of his life but in
the final few years of his life he got
horny
that's like you
yeah and it would it would like you know
try and shag the cushions or
shag their leg or whatever and they
would push it off and go no no don't
don't do that and as they pushed it off
it still had a a couple of little like
pelvic jerks going on they couldn't stop
so he said that they would like kick it
off and go stop that and then it would
walk off into the corner and as it was
walking off it would be like
still trying to get the last couple of
jerks jeff does that oh really
um
well great
even though it will be wet and chilly in
most parts of the country running will
still be a huge part of people's lives
trying to achieve their personal best
the wool dasher mizzle a weather
repellent performance running shoe is
the first shoe of its kind it's
sustainably made from natural materials
with a low environmental impact on the
planet fantastic shoes dom and as you
say sometimes you don't want to go out
and do some running but when you've got
good shoes that helps you out i tell you
that and i tell you dom i'll wear mine
when i'm not running i like to just wear
them just about town and looking good
guys they look fantastic they're
extremely comfortable you feel great
wearing them because they're good for
the environment i'm not a big runner
myself i know you run a little bit more
than me you say they're fantastic
they're great i love them dumb they're
just they're just a brilliant shoe and
they look great as well i absolutely
love mine i do and and also they look
different so you've got a kind of
different looking tube which i like you
feel like yeah i'm being a bit of a
rebel here and also all birds built the
wool dasher mizzle using natural
materials to have a low environmental
impact so you can break a sweat without
breaking the planet this winter keep
your feet cozy and dry with the all
birds wool dasher missiles discover your
perfect pair at allbirds.com today
that's a l l b i r d s dot com
oh tom that really makes me
ah yes the sound of another sale on
shopify the all-in-one commerce platform
to start run and grow your business yeah
i love how shopify has all the tools and
the resources for all your businesses to
succeed from down the street to around
the globe yeah your wife used it doesn't
she and loves it for all of you who
don't know our very own the friendship
onion website is powered by shopify oh
yeah we love it without it all you
lovely people would have no way of
receiving our friendship onion
merchandise like ours shopify powers
millions of businesses from first sale
to full scale you can reach customers
online and across social networks with
an ever-growing suite of channel
integrations and apps including facebook
instagram ticktop pinterest and more
shopify gains insights as you grow with
detailed reporting of conversion rates
profit margins and all that stuff it's
really much more than a store shopify
grows with you this is possibility
powered by shopify go to shopify.com
onion all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
right now that's shopify.com
well let's let's talk about the bachelor
because i want to i want to ask nick
some questions i have yeah a lot of
stories were you what season of the
bachelor did you feature in
21. oh wow that's the first one you're
in so you knew well that's the season i
was the bachelor okay so obviously you
knew about the show you what do you have
to be a fan of the show watch it to get
through the whole casting thing
no i mean i was familiar with it when i
first went on board you were already in
the bachelorette
where you you get casted on the
right so that so first you're one of
many
before you could ever be the one the one
yeah
i've i've never seen the bachelor all
the bachelorette i know jimmy kimmel's a
big fan because he talks about a lot on
his show and he's told it to me honestly
because i've not seen it it seems a bit
obscene
one girl or one guy is looking for a
a choice of
how many people are at the start 30
30.
and can she it can he or she do anything
if she feels if he or she feels inclined
can they be like right we're closing the
door good night
give this a test the perception of that
yes but in reality you are filming a
show so there's obligations as the as
the lead or the bachelor to
fulfill to not do that like as your is
is your contract that you sign huge
whereas like
you can't talk about any of this you
can't do this you can't do that you can
restrict it it's it's kind of like uh
what they have it's people always ask is
it scripted
and it's not at all at all scripted but
it's staged so yeah
you know it's
they give you rooms to play in so it's
kind of like you know hey
we have to stay in this room yep you can
do whatever you want in this room okay
so there's boundaries of things you can
do
um let's take it right right back so you
started on the bachelorette right yeah
what is the audition process to get on
the bachelorette what age are you at
this point how old
was i was i was older for the for
i was 33. okay
and you they just held an open edition
or you knew a friend my friend's wife
signed me up okay without me knowing and
then i got a brilliant i got a call
i was in san francisco for work and i
got a call and they were like hey this
is so and so from abc the bachelor are
you still interested
in being honest
what are you talking about and they're
like well you know and then they and i
think they were typically used to a
reaction like that it's like oh maybe
maybe your friends signed you up but
we're gonna i was living in chicago at
the time
so
and they will do
casting visits their casting department
will go to major cities you know like
chicago and and do like a
to meet locals right so we'll be there
in chicago we'd love to meet you so at
the time my first reaction was there's
no way i'm going to go on but at that
point in my life i
i'd never been to la i didn't know
anything about tv or entertainment so my
i i was like sure i thought it would be
fun to just kind of go through the
process just to see what that was like
yeah yeah yeah uh fully expecting
uh to to you know to either not get
casted or decline if they if they asked
and then
so you're on that tv show yeah and you
did really well on it right
well that's how you uh yeah yeah i i was
a focal point of the season yeah so then
you get asked back to another
bachelorette well then i was involved in
that
in world and as you know just like
actors might date actors and it's it's a
it's a traumatic experience that you go
through and so they have new seasons and
i became friends with the girl who was
on the next season right they casted her
as the bachelorette and we had this bond
or connection and they found out about
it and
i i had a crush on her at the time and
and so they they gave me the opportunity
if i wanted to pursue her
on the show and i i said yes
so now you're living in italy at by this
point and after that experience i moved
to l.a okay
and
the bachelor and the bachelorette
includes this
flower giving it's a rose yeah
and that means that means you've been
selected for the next round it's uh yeah
it's like yeah exactly it's um but each
week there's one less rose
not well it depends it's a you know good
any given week
two one might go home two three just
depends on you know the producers will
decide you know it depends on what's
going on how much
it really depends on what's going on in
the back of mind they're always thinking
you know per episode how is this going
to fit how do we want to air this they
they're they're filming a show oh yeah i
know it's no secret
i'm saying obviously
emotions are involved i mean obviously
throughout the course of so many seasons
of the bachelor in the bachelorette
clearly people have fallen in love
clearly people have broken up there's
been emotions
involved in your time on
those specific seasons and also
throughout the course of the show
has there been like really
heightened emotions of like you know
something potentially getting physical
or some real serious stuff going on i
wouldn't nothing physical you're not
allowed to do that obviously you're not
allowed you get kicked off uh i in my
out time i've
you know it's it's it's arguing
with the the the conf the fights
are arguments there's never
they've they've flirted with suggesting
there might be a physical altercation
but doesn't it in my experience it's
never right before the ad break they'd
be like oh come back after the break
yeah but
but it just turns into it's really just
petty
very high school petty kind of argument
on a feeling standpoint there's there's
real heartbreak and there's real tears
right
because i mean as you see i mean the
emotions must get
real and get really high it's a social
experiment you guys ever heard of the
stanford prison experience oh yeah the
prisoners in the prison walls
right right yeah you're you're put into
a very controlled environment high
stress high stress lack of sleep you
know and not because it's not always
deliberate it's just yeah take you know
you got to film movies like sometimes
you gotta take time and hurry up and
wait yeah
you're kept in the dark a lot and you
have a singular focus you know there's
no distraction there's no phones no
communication with your family or
friends so then you become obsessed with
whatever it is you're supposed to focus
on and
and then they give you validation
through you know if if the lead likes
you they will validate you obviously
yeah and
and
it's an environment based off
withholding love you spend far more time
away from the person than with them and
so you get to you you know kind of like
in high school when we're younger we
uh you know like we don't get to spend
the night with the people we like or you
know we have to ask ourselves for
permission and it's a lot like that type
of love and so you you romanticize it's
it's a relationship built on the idea of
things not the reality of things but
clearly the producers are manipulating
that whole situation so if they see a
potential
you know uh kind of spark point between
two girls or two guys or a little love
triangle they're gonna lean into that
were there times where you kind of
resented what the producers were doing i
i
you know i think sometimes the producers
are a scapegoat um for cast people go on
to kind of blame their decisions you
know listen they are producing a tv show
and what what i describe them as
they're the friend who tells you to buy
the boat
yeah you know what i'm saying like
practically speaking if you go to a fred
and says hey i'm thinking to buy a boat
what do you think a good friend a
pragmatic friend would be like well
let's weigh the pros and cons yeah it's
going to be fun but you know how much
can you really use it it's a cost an
appreciation
and the one friend will be like you
should totally buy the boat because all
they're thinking about is having a
friend with a boat that would be so much
fun
and
so the producers are that you know they
want you they're not there to tell you
what you shouldn't do if you're thinking
and feeling something they're there to
maximize how you express yourself in any
given moment they're not there to
offer you know uh kind of a
alternative point of view or or you know
it's if they want you to maximize your
emotions so at the end of the day you're
in charge of your own emotions that you
don't make you do anything
you know so but as you say you're in
this environment in the same way that a
lot of lead actors and lead actresses
fall in love in a movie because
you know you're there pretending you're
in love or and it becomes as you say
it's just one focus you're all in this
world together
so if you don't mind me asking and maybe
you don't want to talk about this
because i know you're in a relationship
and all that but you did fall in love
i feel real feelings and i felt like
what felt like real feelings because you
asked someone to marry you right
uh i only proposed when i was the
bachelor when you went
i mean the first season
i probably would have if she didn't
broke up break up with me beforehand and
the second season the same but both of
which rejected me right before the
actual proposal oh god yeah
that's dramatic i'm gonna go back and
watch that we're used to rejection
though aren't we as actors i genuinely
think i am quite good with rejection and
i do think it's because of the job that
we do well you've had a lot of it i've
had a lot of rejections over this fail i
came from a sales background same thing
i just think you know if you do it for a
living where someone you've talked about
this before in terms of if you want to
be an actor and someone doesn't like
what you do they're specifically saying
i don't like you yeah i am not
interested in what you are bringing to
the table or more related to love it's
not so much i don't like you
because in relationships in life it's
more i just like them better oh yeah
which is almost worse yeah you know it's
like you're good but
they're better
and that's the probably i assume you
know well that's i mean that's the same
in acting that's what i mean yeah and
you were all right in the audience you
might nail it but like this person
you know yes sometimes
sometimes your agent's terrible for that
kind of thing
when they go like that they absolutely
loved you you thought you're fantastic
they loved him just a little bit more
yeah yeah you're like what doesn't you
feel helpless right there yeah yeah
right
because you're nothing to work on yeah
but it does make you
much more resilient in the you know just
civilian life that you're walking around
to try something to be like you know
would you like to go for dinner and you
think well the worst that can happen
here is they can say no and because you
get told no so many times in your
professional life you just they just go
no you go right
what about your friend
okay see you later
billy and dom eat the world well tell us
what we've got here nick or have we
already talked about it no we haven't
and we're definitely running and where
is this
where does this originate from uh it's a
family recipe from my dad's side of the
family well so this that's gone
nationwide
has come specifically
i i don't know i'm quite certain my
family didn't create it but do you know
if it came from a certain region of the
united states i don't know no no but i
don't know
as far as it relates to my knowledge of
it
it was my dad's side of the family it's
a snack my dad
hello nick's dad he learned from his
father well
oh yeah yeah well according to um
according to johnny clues here who
you'll see on your right there he is
there he is right there thank you and uh
john will often get things wrong thank
you very much john can we buy this [__]
you see
look at that johnny clueless
i can't believe it oh no you're going to
smell a pickle you said that looked
fantastic today as well skin trousers
i can't believe that johnny clues rubbed
these pickles on my trousers that's a
disgrace
nick you've already started it good yes
you've got it i want to make sure he you
go hold your horses
according to johnny johnny clues who
just absolutely destroyed my troops
you'll have to get those dry cleaned he
says
he said originated during the great
depression
that makes sense there'll be another
great depression because of my trousers
because i love them yeah it's a shame
that they call it the great depression
yeah it's
awful
americans were cutting corners any way
they could
pickles and peanut butter were cheap and
plentiful at the grocery store the
sandwiches including some for peanut
butter and mayonnaise what found
themselves at lunch counters in school
lunches and depression era cookbooks
however today mention the words peanut
butter and pickled slices in the same
sentence you'll probably hear a
proclamation of disgust give us a quick
proclamation of disgust
there you go yeah good example now is
this something you've known since you
were a little kid yeah and is this like
a a comfort food for you do you eat it
when you maybe are hungover do you eat
when you're watching a movie what is
this
as a kid it was just a regular snack i
enjoyed and as an adult it'll be
something that i'd be like
usually what will happen it will be
something you know if i get a new
girlfriend or or
or a friend or and i
and we'll be talking like something
versus
like some version of this yeah like you
gotta try it and then i'll remind myself
how much i like it and it's a good snack
to have in would jeff have a bait of
this or not
sure definitely anything that i let him
oh
in the country the good old uncle us of
stateside do you think um a lot of
people know this or is this kind of a
strange sandwich for people even rarely
most people are surprised but once in a
while i'll
encounter someone who will also
vouch for it i had almost had a billy
you almost you almost did a billy boyd
there i'm going to give mine i'm going
to give mine a bite johnny's already
getting stuck yeah john's loving it i
tend to put this
i tend to put more peanut butter on
there should be more peanut butter
apparently
hold on john's coming with more
right hope i'm going to wait and get it
the way that you like it nick because no
we don't want to get it the wrong way
what i'm liking it right hold on it's
very good but stick a bet on there which
is a little bit more peanut butter um
yeah slather a bit of peanut butter all
over his sound come on all over his
trousers
the pants have gone john
there you go
look at that you look like a thingy you
look like a what'd you call those guys
idiot
the guys have been put the thing on the
wall would you it was a pasta raster
peter and labourer right here we go now
i would have you'd think the combination
of pickles and peanut butter don't go
well but they're both salty aren't they
so the salt it kind of
peanut butter
primarily doesn't like it
generally doesn't like it i don't think
it doesn't like it
i like it
you're one yeah i feel
it tastes like something you go it's all
right remove the pickle it'll be better
no i actually quite like it wait a
minute
great i would say
a great hangover cure because suppose if
you hung over drinking pickle juice is a
good idea
so eating pickles with peanut butter
which is also good for a hangover would
be good how's bread for hangover no i
don't think great right size two out of
three initially we well like that
meatloaf song right
do you feel the same
um that's getting better initially you
were you had suggested uh banana and
mayonnaise sandwiches was not nice
definitely not me i don't i'm not a fan
of i came from neither mayonnaise nor a
banana john's telling us that it came
from a ceiling fan is that right came
from a ceiling fan oh a fan
sorry a fan sent us in
banana and mayonnaise sandwiches and i
would say that another time no i said
that sounds like a nightmare if i were
french absolutely none
would you let someone peel your banana
i don't know i wouldn't
i don't like bananas all right i will
put bananas in smoothies because i can't
taste it because they already freeze it
do you freeze it first no freeze your
banana before you have it in a smoothie
then you get a cold smoothie oh yeah i'm
only just put ice in it because i'd
rather have a fresh i don't like to die
of smoothies
it was a it was a bodybuilder a woman
bodybuilder who told me and she says
that is a secret was it fat i'm a bread
no
okay do you have any strange things with
food like i have don't touch my eggs
don't touch my beans don't touch my
bread you have don't touch my fruit
i'll tell you something a little strange
about about you because you cook for me
quite a bit
you tend to be quite sparing with
seasoning no
you are i am not
you ask my wife she goes
crazy when i'm at your house you'll
bring a wonderful mashed potato some
vegetables a piece of fish and i'll
always say if you got any salt and
pepper and then you'll run off and go oh
yeah salt and pepper it's like you bring
it without anything oh my wife would
would disagree with you there tom sorry
i don't know what my wife really hates
whenever i saw anything i throw the salt
over my left shoulder
for the devil for the devil because he's
at your shoulder nick he's at your
shoulder at all times and he doesn't
like salt in his eye if there's one
thing the devil doesn't like salt in his
eye
always over your left shoulder but my
wife hates that because obviously it
lands on the floor well now supposedly
the major um
like
formative structure of a devil is
similar to a slug
it's true and as we know slugs respond
to salt very badly you'll kill a slug if
you have salt on us see if our slugs
have it suck in your blood
uh
a little bit of salt there's no there's
a difference between a slug and a leech
oh it's a massive difference a
completely different animal
yeah um
but a slug will eat all of your garden
vegetables or your fruits and stuff so
my dad every so often will leave little
sources of beer
around the garden and slugs love beer
but
they're complete alcoholics so they'll
drink so much beer they we'll kill them
so you'll see a whole bunch of um dead
slugs the next day which is not the
worst way to die they basically got
drunk yeah and then dying and died from
drinking too much
like richard burton
did he die in your dad's garden yeah he
did eating my dad's vegetables this is
good i'm sorry i'm starting to like give
it away
it takes a little getting you tell us
about something strange about the way
that you eat i'm trying to think don't
but i can't think of anything that i am
i don't like i don't mind people
bringing me a fruit bowl in fact i'd i'd
probably thank them if someone they
brought me a a nice a bowl of fruit
i would have to try not to be rude yeah
i'll eat that later or something my
because my my natural reaction would be
like oh
i'm like wow
how dare you bring me a chair i would i
would my innards would be offended yeah
yeah and then if somebody touched your
bread if somebody said to you look i've
made your perfect sandwich marmite
english cheese
rocket all i can think i'm not finished
yet go and go on the street vinegar
yeah there's one thing miss english
yeah um that was that no are you sure
yeah what else um
[Music]
you've done the crisp rocket cheese
butter
that's it no slice of green apple slice
of green apples splash the green apple
you would see them no thank you i would
probably say fat i wouldn't say no thank
you
i can't oh cheese and apples fantastic
mature english cheddar and a bite of an
apple and they're maturing this cheddar
that is a great flavor combination isn't
it well
i just said it your english cheddar
apples
just getting my pickle in my mouth there
that's beg your pardon you were the
first person to tell me in new zealand
of a strange flavor combination which
goes really well uh together
strawberries and balsamic vinegar utah
delicious
you just dip the strawberries in
balsamic vinegar you can see that um
uh no it must enhance the flavor of the
strawberry yeah it does brings out the
sweetness of it if someone brought me a
sandwich i would of course say thank you
but i would be constantly i would be
fixated on how much they've touched the
bread in moving it around and fashioning
all the things on top of it i'm all
right with my mum or my dad making a
sandwich on my brother you're right
because people get handsy with bread if
they make you a sandwich it's like they
almost
forget that that could be a new thing
for you nick that you won't be able to
have a sandwich now is there not
something that everyone else likes and
you're just like nah i'm not into it i
don't like cinnamon
yeah you don't like cinnamon do you you
know no i don't i used to i used to
really hate cinnamon i as a kid i you
would snack we would make is toast
butter and cinnamon well that's where it
started next
house no somebody else's house we were
on our way to a fun fair like you know
six flags or something and they made
that
in america
and they made me toast and butter and
cinnamon and i ate it and then i went on
a big dipper and i was sick to my
stomach now
i think i always always thought
yeah yeah
it's a it's an unfortunate coincidence
that you win on that ride but i'm
starting to get i'm starting to get back
on you cinnamon but i still i wouldn't
thank you for it
john's saying would ma might work on
pickles and peanut butter on no
not with peanut butter i wouldn't say
don't think that pickle and and cheese
marmite's very savory and you need
something a bit
more
in the savory world
we should give it some scores nick we
score these things in three separate
categories okay
taste
aesthetics looks the look of it
usefulness
you can choose
it's actually the same scoring they use
on the bachelor yeah yeah
yeah so looks it's out of ten no taste
taste i mean yeah taste
taste
there's only two things that have had a
perfect 10 and only from dom
marmite i mean i'm biased this is like
my you brought up childhood
favorite snack wow
mine's moabs and we'll have moans on
on another episode
i mean you did a fantastic job and i
thank you johnny johnny for making this
you know we're in a studio and he had to
use a uh
an oven but yeah it's not very early
fresh off the toaster i also like it on
an english muffin oh gosh
as the toast base
i haven't
or a pikelet i've not have you had a pie
club no i enjoyed the top but if you
have a really hot piece of toast and a
lot of gooey melted peanut butter and a
pickle
well you should try a crumb that's when
it's a real turn a crumpet is basically
a pie club with a big fat ass and a pie
clutch is like a
we're talking about food still yeah it's
like a it's like a condensed pancake
isn't it a pikelet i don't know what pie
club you're not competitive right i
don't know what a crumpet so imagine a
crumpet with the top three inches cut
off so you basically just got the base
that's a pie clutch oh i've never had a
pie crust
packets are good they might be just a
northern thing but a crumpet with peanut
butter and a uh
lovely enjoy it i crump it because it
all melts in oh that's lovely i'm
getting more and more used to this and
it's i'm doing in my last
my last bite and it's the perfect break
nick's giving it 10. how much are you
going to give it out william boyd i'm
only giving it six point four five i
mean hey you started at a two exactly
i'm gonna give it
i'm gonna give it a 7.3 out of ten well
done
aesthetics how does it look how does it
look to you nick
well again i've it's not the belly
unfortunately i'm familiar yeah it's
it's not the most beautiful thing i've
ever seen i think that's what makes it
so flavorful is because it it it
presents as
potentially harmful to you
it's a sneaky
sneaky delicious snack yeah i mean so
you know it's a three or four yeah in
terms of looks a three or a four so do
you want to give it a 3.5 yeah i'll give
it a 3.5
i think
it's not ugly though
i'm going to give it a 6.9
i'll give it a 6.5 oh lovely lovely it's
not terrible but it's it's bread and
peanut butter and pickles i mean it's
not it's not changing the world is it
usefulness useful now sometimes we have
things on here
that are very useful you can put it in a
pie you can make ice cream from it you
can you know what i mean you can travel
with it you can bring it to a party
we learned that this was
invented during the great depression
when when people didn't have people
literally needed
but we have to exactly we have to find
something hold on
something phil
people really take to the acidic
vinegary taste of the pickles combined
with the rich and subtle sweet and salty
taste of the peanut butter they also
like the crunch of the pickles with the
smooth creamy cream crunch in the pickle
is a very satisfying moment so does that
make it any more useful
well what to find useful because you say
well to me i think practical
in general you know you could this is a
good this is a you can eat this for
breakfast lunch or dinner it's a snack
it should be fair you can i've also
noticed someone who's eaten this my
whole life that most grocery stores
will have their peanut butter and
pickles
next to each other well look as if
they're trying to is this as if
this has been a thing for
some time not everyone i noticed
i noticed this at an early age and now
when i go to a new grocery store i will
see if they many grocery stores will put
their peanut butter and their pickle
selection
not only in the same aisle but quite
literally
each other
so it's easy to shop for
and you can pack it for a plane yeah
you don't need to like warm it up for it
to be good i mean yeah like if you made
a sandwich it's not gonna be your best
version of it i was gonna say if you
have kids playing you know a sports game
or whatever and you're showing up late
to pick them up and take them home or
watch the second half if you brought
peanut butter and pickle sandwiches
they're not going to spoil they're
pretty portable
and they're good for after a sports game
and as nick says if you're
maybe get a new friend and you're
chatting to them you're chatting about
food do you know any weird food wait
till i tell you about my childhood i'd
say it's a great it's an easy bet to win
it's a curiosity because most people
aren't familiar with it we'll bet that
they don't like it and they normally do
yeah and like
and it's a great way to like yeah and
then and then you know it breaks down
like yeah it breaks a good conversation
yeah and it's a great way to tell people
i told you so yeah i do think most
things can be eaten for breakfast lunch
it's very satisfying when your
girlfriend told you she would never like
it and it becomes her favorite snack oh
so it's useful and that see i was
thinking of manipulation
we we did a thing on this show once in
billion doll meet the world with the
jardinera do you know what that is i
heard of it but what is it it's like
pickled um
uh vegetables vegetables
no jalapenos it's like a it's like a
topping yeah
that thing no that if we had to do that
again and we did useful i would give
that 10. because i use it in everything
now it's great and pasta is green pizza
it's great in anything for breakfast you
judge usefulness by versatility yes
but i see what you're saying and i like
it breaks the ice i like that it's a
it's a conversation piece i think that
makes it useful so i'm going to go with
8.5
i just bought our friend nigel a big jar
of jardineria very careful
yeah i am a kind man because he never
had it and i was like i'm sending it to
you you'll love it and he does love it i
have it sometimes for breakfast i just
take a spoonful drain out the oil
straight in my mouth and then straight
to the toilet and it has a right good
[__] yeah i do i love this [__]
um
so
usefulness
i think they're saying i do think it's
quite versatile like you said in it it's
a good good choice of words i'm going to
give it what did you give it 8.5
yeah i'll give it an 8.5 wow that's not
bad what do you think nick
i'm going to go with 9.5 jeezy weezy
that's a high school you can't use it in
every food but it has versus
a variety of benefits in situations
situational benefits it's not unhealthy
for you especially if you pick the right
peanut butter not unhealthy i don't know
how healthy but it's not unhealthy there
are worse
and it's it's a savory snack you know
like a dessert yeah if you think if
you're trying to peanut you're trying to
stay away from like sweets and candy but
you still liked a good dessert or
something
yeah that's almost one yeah it's like
you would still get that kind of
satisfaction
of like
i think you have to be mindful of what
peanut butter you use because some
peanut butter is absolutely awful for
you because yeah it's full of
hydrogenated fat and i thought they were
all just like a hundred percent no no no
no no
[Music]
nick you've brought us a fantastic song
for us to uh rate if it's funky or not
this is a song that i grew up with oh
wait a minute john i was going to say
something about last week because
remember we had ramstein ramstein was on
last and i thought i i thought it was
the the band that won the eurovision
song contest remember that fizz no but i
found this skirt stuff one of our
listeners wrote to us and told us who
was the band that won
the eurovision song contest and it was a
finnish band
and they were called you'll never get it
you won't know so that great story bills
i was hoping johnny was going to come
out great great story there one of our
one of our one of our listeners told us
who the band was that i thought it was
last week with ramstein
i don't know
oh god
both as bad as each other
i don't know how you managed to get
through that's what i used to do to me
we did ramstein last week to know
remstein
pretty sure they're a german band yeah
anyway
we're getting too deep and
there's a rabbit hole well you told a
story that had no ending well i had a
half an ending all right so
we do we ask our guests each week to
pick a song that they think is funky you
must have grown up with this song the
same way that i did i think i was eight
or nine when it came out and it was my
favorite song on the planet yeah for
that summer it reminds me of my father
uh-huh and my father would often he had
like a saturday morning tradition of
peanut butter and pickles blasting his
favorite tunes and i would like wake up
to this and so it's kind of nostalgic
for me and then
and then when i learned about the origin
of the songs i thought it was even
cooler and also a band that has had some
incredible songs over the years and
we'll talk about that in a sec but
should we listen to the song first let's
listen here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
all lordy cup look at him you're yours
that's the way you do it
hey what's he doing with his guitar
there he's got some sort of flange on it
he's got flanger doesn't it the reason i
say flange specifically there is you
know that word flange is attributed to
john lennon is it george martin had
explained a little effect that they'd
put on the guitar and george martin said
that's kind of a little bit of this and
a little bit of that with the little
flange and john john lennon said what
flange you went yeah flange it's so it's
this kind of thing that we call it so
from then on over the years in recording
john would say put a bit of flange on
that guitar and flange became the word
for the thing but it was kind of just a
nickname for it john lennon but what are
they doing with the guitar there's a lot
of genomic guitar there the thing with
uh knopfler was he he never used the
pick did he was all just fingers right
he was all fingers he he was really he's
all fingers and thumbs he was he was a
very good kind of picker so it sounds
like he's doing a big round and
but i do remember the name
of what of the band who won the
eurovision song contest fizz
lordy a lordy lordy one of our listeners
wrote in and says the band who won the
eurovision song contest that i was
trying to find the name of last week
were called lordy lordy miss claudie
there you go first first album i ever
bought in my life
brothers in arms by dire straits which
includes this song and also walk of life
and the song brothers at arms which is
incredible they're a great fan yeah
they're amazing romeo and juliet
remember that song they do a kind of a
modern new york version of romeo and
juliet
sultan's a swing ah
it's pretty funky here's the thing i
don't like about dire stripes though
they always make me think of like a pub
band because pub bands always play a lot
of dire straights so then i think dire
straits are kind of pub band yeah
they're not really yeah because they're
quite quite sophisticated what was the
first record you bought
bought or owned like as a like bought
actually took the money took the money
so maybe you're [__] are you too
young you got the money and went down
and bought a record
well there are for cds cds oh i was
buying records we're a lot older than
you yeah that's a shame well i i my
first i had a cassette was gifted to me
before i could afford it yeah
this is an embarrassing answer i love
that it was the
soundtrack to biodome
why you doing with polyshore and it's
it's a movie so yeah it's a bad movie a
poly sure soundtrack that's brilliant
it's an embarrassing
who did the soundtrack do you know no
it's a you know a variety of songs
i've never been that musically
intelligent and so i would buy like i
would watch a movie and and like it like
this music that the fed likes the movie
you know i saw this movie when i was
like a teenager i was a big pauly shore
fan back in his heyday
paulie shore and um
who's the baldwin stephen baldwin steve
and one of them which was shawn aston in
it he was in a lot of movies
he was an encino man well first of all
yeah which was called california man in
the uk yeah because there's nothing new
that makes sense i mean i didn't know
what i didn't see like i was from a kid
from wisconsin so yeah it might as well
could have been anything yeah here's my
hands yeah yeah where if my hand was the
united states of america you could do
the right do you think that's better
yeah yeah because then you've got the no
handle yeah yeah no i can't do that i
don't know how i did it you did it how
did it get america oh there yeah there
you go so there's florida yeah
california
new york canada mexico
where
is wisconsin don't give them any clues
nick wisconsin
i'm gonna guess
[Music]
yeah yeah it's the cheese steak is that
right cheese heads that's quite a lot of
cheese there or you make cheese there
is that what it is right there yeah you
make cheese the east is more condensed
than the west
yeah that's true there's a lot of states
up there yeah there's not many states
here and there's hardly any over there
but why are you called the cheese state
well it used to be now california is it
has been for 30 years but they used to
they still do but used to produce the
most amount of dairy dairy farms it's
known for dairy farms
okay but california has been producing
more dairy for the past 30 40 years
let's rate diet straights money for
nothing out of a level of funk so we do
it out of a level of brahms which is no
funk to prince which is a high level of
funk or anything in between but funk
doesn't have to we're not talking it has
to be funk funk
traditionally it's just is it funky to
me does it make me feel like
yeah was fun
um
see because of the the you don't like
dinosaurs well no i don't can't see see
all the ones you mentioned romeo juliet
i love those
but i would never i wouldn't put an
album on and it was because it's because
of the pub thing oh yeah you know and
and so because of that i'm i'm
i'm gonna have to go towards the
classical
i'm gonna but people like to play
so i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say
middle of the road you too
okay okay not that funky but it is it's
not you two when they're yeah or youtube
and they're like whoa
but just like
you know unforgettable fire yeah okay
i'm gonna say
jermaine jackson funk oh i found them
quite funky quite funky
we don't have to take our clothes off
what was that
was that not janet no that wasn't he was
a guy unless unless janet
would suddenly turn masculine
do you remember
[Music]
and what did he drink and drink some
cherry wine
remember that's all
brilliant i've only had a couple of
conversations with you over since we've
got to know you but i like i like how
you look at the world you've got a good
sort of i like things like the you
notice that the peanut butter and the
pickle are next to each other yeah in
the store i like that kind of mindscape
and i like that you like your new dog i
like i was just about to say i like your
ongoing evolving beautiful close
relationship with your doggy work and if
you want to do an animal communication
class i'll let you know let me know do i
still smell good i don't know what i
haven't smelled you hold on give me
sniff go on headphones
hang on wait we're waiting baited breath
baited breath did he smell a pickle
i can confirm you still smell good and
do you know what when i was on my way
here today i noticed my cologne and i
thought i might spray a little bit on
because nick's coming in today yeah yeah
give him a little spray but i forgot
okay because usually you smell a dog
dirt i don't smell too good natural you
usually smell a duct tape you smell
great though i think
you have a neutral smell yeah i don't
smell of anything i'm like the guy in
perfume nick it's been great having you
and we'll see you around we both share
the same podcast studio so we'll see you
around great to see you mate thanks for
coming on guys if you want to get in
touch with us you can do that at uh the
friendship on your castmedia.com that's
cass with a k and before we go we should
let you know that the holiday merch is
still available and the best thing that
we've sold so far that i like is the red
holiday christmas hoodie it's cozy it
looks great it's almost kind of
manchester united red fantastic we'll
get you one next yeah we'll get it free
it's free we're gonna give you one for
free but you can only get it for like
another day so if you want to get any of
the holiday merch get it now friendship
on your podcast.com chat
friendshipburningbroadcast.com and if
you want to leave us a message please do
tell us what you want to see or hear on
the show or any info and you can leave
that at the
speak pipe dot com forward slash the
friendship onion see you next week
harmonize with me and hold me back all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your host the baby you're my
[Music]